well I we have a not my roommate anymore
but this is guy named ray Ray's the man
dude actually lo ray I'll tell you this
right now I actually was trying to take
ray with me when I left that's how much
I love ray take him take him with you
where to move in with me oh my Muriel
said no what's I don't know so tell me
what's okay right right okay let me just
tell you something real quick about tell
me some Raymond [ __ ] Park aka
reggae man ka-who what else right killer
ray Killa
Raymundo actually known ray since I was
like 2 years old right Ray has been ray
is always one of those dude we call him
the silent but deadly [ __ ]
killer dude he's always quite this
[ __ ] don't sit I've never seen
him sit in my life yeah he never sits
stands all the [ __ ] time but he's
like that type of roommate super-clean
always comes in with those slight little
jokes never really expected if
something's busted in the house the next
day you best believe ray Killa fixed it
doesn't even have to be asked takes out
the trash does everything that's kind of
roommate love ray to death I wanted to
take him with me
Muriel said no she says this true story
is that a bit yes I was trying to take
him with legit and I was legit kind of
jealous like I hope he doesn't leave is
he still with you yeah he's okay yep I
known him since I was two two years old
grew up in Sacramento California woody
the same church we went to he went to UC
Davis I went to UCR and then when I
moved back to LA he actually moved back
at the same time and lo and behold I got
in to move in with me and I kept I held
onto him for [ __ ] six years this lady
named Ariel song comes around and strips
him away from me is he single is he cute
he is single and I love ray let me tell
you something let me take some Mouse you
don't deserve him you're not you're
you're too damaged for him
we're like damaged girls don't this
makes things more exciting
yeah we like we like dents in our cars
we don't want the engine missing missing
I might have a crack or two in the
transmission by I might need my oil
changed by Ray is a unique guy that like
you have to get to know him to
understand his humor and he's super
quiet but once you get him to speak and
he opens up man
ray is funny been like I love ray he's a
very simple guy to you you want to talk
about minimalist he's a minimalist so if
you [ __ ] with minimalist racing the type
of guy if Ray falls in love with you
just best belief he has everything in
your best interest he takes care of me
till this day if Mary old eyes I'm never
gonna get back with somebody ever again
I'm going to be afraid right
me and Ray will be single till the death
of us I'm actually speaking for him I
don't care if you find that we're we're
together now I think I've just fallen in
love do Ray's great dude I [ __ ] love
Rayman Rayman you have been with me
since I was a hoodlum and he still stuck
around
shoutout to Ray Ray Park Raymond Killa
dude
Raymond but you had that type of
relationship with Megan but once Megan
butuan that's her French named megabats
Juan seguín butuan yeah how did you and
Merritt up Mariel Megan meat we love
telling this story I was actually really
mean to her the first time we about what
a Korean [ __ ] yep I was in her eyes
basically in the dance culture there's
like a thing that we like to call
groupies and I just based off of who
Megan was hanging out with when I first
met her I just kinda sumed she was one
too and we were at this house party in
Vegas
shoutout to jr. Aquino is his house
oh the singer is a very fantastic scene
yeah amazing singer we were all at his
house and I think it was actually my
birthday week to where we're all in
Vegas for HHI which is this big hip-hop
competition and yeah she was at this
house party as well this is back when I
had like shaved sides and stuff and she
yeah yeah dude dude I used to have a
pixie cut
bleached platinum blonde and
Faye's for sure and then yeah so Megan
was at this party and she comes up to me
she's like hey I really like your
haircut and me thinking she was just
another groupie I was like yeah it's the
same as yours and then walked away damn
what a [ __ ] I was a mean girl I was a
mean girl and then fast forward one year
later I was running movement life style
at the time and she had just moved to LA
and she was taking some classes at the
studio and I don't know I think I just
forgot that that happened and we were
getting along she's I think she brought
up she's like yeah we actually met last
year party and I was like I was like
sorry I don't remember and she kind of
like refreshed my memory and she like
jokingly brought up the story about the
haircut and I was like oh my god I
totally remember I'm so sorry that I was
mean to you because I really liked her
in in this environment and so just
judged them all I really did and then
you know mm-hmm I think like that same
week or like the next week I had put up
on my facebook that I was looking for a
roommate and she hit me up and I was
like yeah I come check out the place if
you are interested and then yeah just
look together yeah and then we lived
together in that particular apartment
for five years
the one where I did that ghetto ass [ __ ]
yes talk show oh yeah
if there's anybody that's resourceful
it's that girl you want to talk about
come up dude
yeah that's to Megan she definitely came
up yeah yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] lady won't
come on my talk show I saw I was like yo
talk about rinky-dink dude yeah it's
crazy you saw the video it doesn't look
Rica dude I'm saying like she's my last
[ __ ] she knows how to make
something out of nothing for sure yeah
yeah so we lived in that apartment for
four years and then we moved to another
apartment oh no I think that apartment
was four or five years and then another
apartment for one year so but we've
known each other for now maybe 7 you
guys split what was that like it was
fascinating it was a such a growth
experience for the both of us like for
me it I had already lived by myself
prior to this apartment with her so I've
had experience living on my own but she
had never at this point
and so she just really wanted to know
what it was like to live by herself and
yeah be an independent woman and so I
was like yeah it was like we're not
gonna live together forever so it was
about time and did you guys have that
friends moment where Monica we took a
picture in our empty apartment so we're
so corny we set up the camera and it was
like I think we were like hugging each
other and it's like we set up like a
self-timer camera with this empty
apartment which is like a couple of
boxes you know it was fun but we've had
like in terms of roommates it was like
the easiest thing ever like because she
loves to cook and I love to cook we
would always like make random meals she
like back then when I was more involved
in the dance community I had so many
people constantly like looking for
places to stay and she never once
complained about me having like people
over all the time like I was that girl
that always had people over I would have
killed you oh I was really looking to
admit like hey you [ __ ] maniac yeah
get these [ __ ] homeless people out of
my house not homeless squatter she never
she never complained like there at one
point like there was this entire crew of
Aussie boys that I knew that they were
all in LA for I forget why I we had four
or five Aussie boy dancers you would
talk about smelly guys and she like
didn't care that I like gave them a
place to stay like how many days I don't
remember it was so long ago how many
days maybe a week lost your [ __ ] mind
terrible roommate you are that's how
cool she is terrible you are in a person
Hey no we we were great roommates I mean
that's why we lived together for so long
is just a it worked out so well you what
here's the [ __ ] plot twist it's like
I just want to live on Milo's like no
you don't matter that one time you
bought those [ __ ] four guys over we
spent let me taste on this now this is
how I am as a person my thing is like
when we when we live together there's
certain rules that we have right like
the great thing about like me and
Cleveland we lived together we never had
anybody over
like house is like home base for us
right occasionally we'll bring a one or
two people over but they wouldn't be
staying for [ __ ] long right because
our there's our spot but we got it we
got a destress here right so